good evening everyone thank you all so
much for coming out on this Friday night
my name is Michael tribe Wasser I'm a
bookseller and supervisor here at
politics and prose bookstore and on
behalf of the owners of the staff I'd
like you welcome all to tonight's event
before we get going just a couple of
housekeeping items first of all if you
could turn off or silence your
cellphone's be greatly appreciated for
the Q&A please remember to step up to
the microphone that we have set up right
over here on your right before asking
your questions as we are being filmed hi
folks at home and so we can all it's
being recorded and we can all hear and
partake in the conversation copies of
tonight's book are all behind the
registers at the front of the store if
you'd like to purchase one and I highly
recommend that you do lastly after the
event would be a great help to us if you
fold up your chairs and laying them up
against the nearest wall or bookshelf
but now on to the main event I'm very
excited to introduce Kate Anderson
Brower Kate previously worked for CBS
News in New York and Fox News here in
Washington DC she then covered the Obama
White House for four years for Bloomberg
News she's the author of The New York
Times number-one bestseller the
residents inside the private world of
the White House I can stand here before
you and honestly say that the residence
is one of my favorite books any time a
customer asked me for a nonfiction
recommendation in paperback you can
usually find me walking over to it
before they can even really finish their
sentence in her new book first women the
Grace and power of America's modern
first ladies Kate shines a light on one
of the most misunderstood and
challenging of roles that of the First
Lady of the United States as she did
with the residents she shares an
astonishing amount of stories from
various first lady's as well as well as
their closest associates the stories
range from shocking to tragic to
heartfelt first woman is already a New
York Times bestseller and has gotten
great reviews
USA Today wrote and that is a
surprisingly deep look at the women who
help and sometimes overshadow
they're powerful husbands I'm positive
that I now have a new nonfiction
recommendation for visitors here coming
to the bookstore and so without further
ado please help me in welcoming Kate
Anderson Brower thank you very much that
was the nicest intro I've ever gotten so
you made my day so yeah I wrote a book
called the residence about the maids and
butlers at the White House that came out
last year and that inspired me to write
this book about the first lady's because
when I spoke with the household staff at
the White House they would often say
when a decision comes from the second
floor that means it's coming from the
East Wing from the first lady herself
and I always thought that was really
interesting their relationship with the
first lady
led me to sort of delve into the role of
first lady and what is it like it's one
of the hardest jobs I think because
there is no you know job description for
it they don't have any idea of really
what they are supposed to do and you're
kind of stand if you do and damned if
you don't
and I interviewed three first ladies for
the residents Laura Bush Barbara Bush
and Rosalyn Carter and I went back and
interviewed Rosalyn for this book and
was just really amazed at how candid she
was in our interview and how very honest
she was about how difficult it is to
watch your husband and campaign for your
husband and then have him lose an
election and these women work incredibly
hard behind the scenes and especially
with this election that we are going
through as we speak it's going to be
fascinating to see who the presidential
spouse will be and will it be the first
man to ever occupy the role we don't
even know what we call him
the first gentleman I guess who was a
former president of course which will
change the the mold forever and maybe
make it easier for first ladies in the
future to continue their careers and the
perhaps have a you know bigger seat at
the table
women like Hillary Clinton and Rosalyn
Carter you know sat in on cabinet
meetings Hillary Clinton famously had an
office in the West Wing and I think most
people or men
people in this country we're not happy
with the extent of involvement that both
of those women had it in the white house
and so we'll see if Bill Clinton changes
any of that and Melania Trump of course
would be the first immigrant first lady
I mean Louisa Adams was from she was
born in London but her father was
American so it would be really
interesting to see Melania having you
know both of her parents being Slovenian
but I covered the White House for
Bloomberg News and when I was there I
had a lunch with Michelle Obama and
about a dozen other reporters mostly
women who covered the East Wing and at
this lunch that was meant to promote the
let's move campaign it was the
anniversary of her let's move campaign
she made an offhand remark about
President Obama finally kicking his
smoking habit and that became the huge
headline from this lunch and that also
made me think you know the whole lunch
was very staged and and she was really
not very you know was it was something
that was meant to promote the signature
issue and the one-off hands kind of
honest comment she made totally overtook
the whole point of the lunch and so that
also made me think about the limitations
placed on these women the pressure put
on them and they are constitutionally
required to be perfect when I it's
really an incredible job when I
interviewed Steve Ford Betty Ford's son
he said my mother wasn't perfect she
said she was an ordinary woman in an
extraordinary time and I think it's
their imperfection and their humanity
that makes them so compelling and
interesting and without these women
their husbands wouldn't have been
elected and that's almost to a person
and I start the book with Jackie Kennedy
mostly because I wanted to interview
people who are still alive and talk to
people who were they are I interviewed a
wonderful woman who was Lady Bird
Johnson social secretary who remembers
the relationship between Jackie and Lady
Bird so I wanted to just start with
Jackie also because she's probably next
to Eleanor Roosevelt the most famous
first lady we've ever had I did more
than 200 interviews with White House
aides first lady's friends and I was
also for this book happy because I got
to speak with
few resident staffers who wouldn't talk
to me for my first book including the
head Butler George Heaney who he was
very tough to get for the first book he
would not answer my phone calls weapon
finally I was able to get an interview
with him and he had some great stories
that were really illuminating about what
it's like for the Obamas in the White
House because he's one of the Butler's
who worked on the second floor and one
thing I thought that he said that was
really interesting was that just the
security concerns that the Obamas and
every first family faces but especially
the Obamas and he talked about how on
the Truman balcony when he they would
want to have dinner outside sometimes
the butler's would suggest that they not
eat outside because there were too many
people crowded around the South Lawn
gates and when they do see the president
and the first lady outside they have to
make sure they're positioned behind
columns I mean it's a really incredibly
stressful place to live and I just
thought that really shed light on the
prison like elements of the White House
that Michelle Obama has talked about a
lot recently and how she can't wait to
leave which again I think is interesting
because she and Hillary Clinton are so
very different I mean Hillary Clinton
can't wait to come back into the White
House and Michelle can't wait to get out
another thing I really wanted to get
into with this book was this profound
sense of empathy that these women have
for each other and so there are these
great letters between them that you can
find in the presidential libraries that
show you know Lady Bird Johnson writing
to Jackie Kennedy and these
relationships that go on well past their
years in the White House and some of
these letters were really touching and
you know Lady Bird writing to Caroline
Kennedy for instance after John Kennedy
Jr's death in the plane crash
and to just think about the incredible
history that the Johnsons and the
Kennedys have had together
Lady Bird was you know in the motorcade
when JFK was killed and and I thought it
was a really interesting window into
this personal dynamic that these women
have and I also thought it was very
sweet that letters that Lady Bird
Johnson would write to other first
lady's she would write in do not answer
in all caps in the margins
because she didn't want them to feel
compelled to write anything if they were
you know sometimes these women would
learn about an illness or you know for
instance when President Reagan was
diagnosed with Alzheimer's there are
some wonderful letters between Betty
Ford and Barbara Bush writing to Nancy
Reagan where they really feel for her
and there's a really incredible kind of
personal element with these letters back
before everyone used email all the time
so it's very nice to see that kind of
personal dynamic one thing I also
thought was really interesting if I
started this book out wondering if there
was a letter that first ladies leave for
each other in the same way that there's
a letter that presidents leave for each
other and I found out that there isn't
you know they don't have any formal
letter but what they do do is they do
this White House tour and that's really
the substitute where you know between
the election in November and the
inauguration in January the outgoing
first lady gives the incoming first lady
or First Gentleman potentially in this
case a tour of the second and third
floors of the White House and during
this tour they offer each other advice
after the 2000 election Hillary Clinton
told Laura Bush not to let the
responsibilities of her new role cloud
her decision-making Hillary had always
regretted turning down an invitation
from Jackie Kennedy Jackie had invited
her and Chelsea to go to the ballet in
New York but Hillary said she was too
busy and couldn't make it and Jackie
passed away a few months later and so
Hillary always regretted that and she
wanted to pass on this piece of advice
to Laura and she also told the word that
she regretted having an office in the
West Wing and I spoke with one Clinton
aide who talked about how you know they
wish that they when they saw the public
reaction to it they wish that they could
have turned back time and not had that
West Wing office and that perhaps she
was too ambitious thinking that she
could recreate the role of first lady
when the public wasn't ready for it
another thing that's very interesting is
there's this one spot where they can
stand where the outgoing first lady and
the incoming first lady stand and then
they can point to the Oval Office and
you can see and through the rose garden
from the second floor from a dressing
room and see into the Oval Office and
every first lady will take the incoming
first lady to the spot and say if you
stand right here you can see your
husband working so it's kind of a way
for them to spy on their husbands and to
feel connected I think in some way to
their lives because they do feel very
confined especially the women a lot of
them I was surprised to learn worked out
of the residence you know Nancy Reagan
really rarely went to the East Wing and
she had one secretary
well close aide who would come from the
East Wing and deliver news to her in the
residence and I think that would be
incredibly claustrophobic you know it's
a huge house but you feel like you're
just confined Betty Ford calls it her
one-bedroom apartment you know feeling
like you're upstairs all the time and
when Laura Bush gave Michelle Obama her
first tour of the White House she was
eager to assure Michelle that a life
could be made there for her daughters
and she wanted the tour to be special in
private even though Michelle had brought
along a staffer and so Laura told
Michelle Zee this is really for Michelle
and I you can meet with my staff but
this is a private visit for us and I
thought that was interesting that
Michelle brought along us in aid because
she came from the corporate world and
she thought that this is what you do but
it was really not in keeping with
protocol and there are a lot of things
that I think you don't know about until
you do them and that's one of those
smaller things that Michelle was
surprised to find out she also brought a
gift which apparently you don't do
either so there are all these little
things that you don't know that are faux
pods that you're not supposed to do
another thing I think that's really
interesting about how Michelle Obama has
approached the role of first lady and
this is something that's seemingly small
but I think it really speaks volumes
about her is that the resident staff
always leaves a folder of information
for the president and the first lady to
review outside on a console table
outside their bedroom on the second
floor and Michelle Obama didn't like
having to walk by this table and see
this work all the time she wanted the
second floor living space to be strictly
for her
otters and and to feel like home to them
as a family and so she asked her for her
folder to be put in an office area off
of the bedroom and for the president's
folder of work to be put in the treaty
room which is essentially an office on
the second floor of the White House and
I think that that's a really interesting
small change but I think it speaks
volumes about how the Obamas have
approached life in the White House with
two young daughters also a White House
uh sure told me they're the first first
family to turn off the lights themselves
on the second floor that before them and
usher would turn off the lights at the
end of the night and I think that also
speaks to their kind of middle class you
know roots whereas the bushes for
instance especially Barbara Bush and
George HW Bush they they grew up with a
lot of wealth and I think they were much
more used to some of this and that's
getting back to my first book but the
resident staff said that they were
really great to work for because they
were used to being catered to in a lot
of ways and I think Michele and and
Michelle Obama and President Obama found
it a little bit more difficult to feel
like someone was always listening in to
their conversations now the
relationships I have a chapter in the
book about the sisterhood among these
women there's one chapter about bad
blood between them that comes out you
know what during campaign season
especially and another chapter about the
sisterhood I do think that the
sisterhood is very powerful and I think
it's really interesting that it doesn't
have to do with party lines you know a
lot of these friendships are between
Republicans and Democrats
for instance Michelle Obama and Laura
Bush are much more similar you know
temperament wise than Michelle Obama and
Hillary Clinton Barbara Bush and Nancy
Reagan really didn't get along at all in
fact someone asked Nancy Reagan after
they left the White House about Barbara
Bush and Nancy said I really didn't get
to know her that well but they had been
there for eight years together and I
interviewed one of Nancy Reagan's very
close aides who said that you know it's
essentially like if your husband is a
law partner and my husband is a law
partner
mean that we have to get along and I
thought that was an interesting sort of
illuminating thing to say about the
dynamic between these women and that
really came out very clearly because
Jackie Kennedy would not go back to the
White House when Lady Bird Johnson asked
her to come back it was too painful for
her after her husband's assassination
and Lady Bird really wanted her to come
back for the dedication of the garden
and her name and Jackie wouldn't go
until Pat Nixon asked her to come back
now more time had passed but it's
interesting to see this meeting between
a Republican first lady and the Democrat
I mean two women who could not be more
different you know standard bearers for
their party and it's a really dramatic
scene where on February 3rd 1971 Jackie
visited the White House for the first
time since her husband's assassination
and the private the private visit she
would only go if no one knew about it
she didn't want any press there and she
went for the unveiling of the official
portraits her portrait and her husband's
portrait and she brought along
thirteen-year-old Caroline and 10-year
old John Kennedy jr. and they had a very
awkward dinner with the Nixon's where
John Kennedy jr. spilled his milk and
apparently lightened the mood
considerably because it was very
difficult for her to go back I mean
there were a lot of happy memories it's
also very sad for her and there are
wonderful letters at the Kennedy Library
that are just incredible that John
Kennedy jr. wrote to Pat Nixon and
President Nixon saying I can never thank
you more for showing us the White House
I really liked everything about it and
he talks about sitting on his the
Lincoln Bedroom bed where his father had
slept and making a wish that he would do
well in school which I think it's very
sweet and so it's kind of a touching
thing that they went for this visit and
that she went back the Jackie went back
when Pat Nixon invited her to these
women were arrivals in 1960 during the
1960 campaign and Pat Nixon even wanted
to recount she was so upset at the
results so this was not an easy
relationship the most poignant letter
though came from Jackie herself written
in her signature spidery handwriting on
her sky-blue stationery can you imagine
the gift you gave us to return to the
White House privately with my little
ones while they are still young enough
to rediscover their childhood she wrote
the day I always dreaded turned out to
be one of the most precious ones I've
spent with my children may God bless you
all and I just think that that shows the
humanity among these women that they do
go through so much and they do
understand very intimately what it's
like to live in the White House and to
go through you know the sort of security
concerns and in the painful loss of
Jackie Jackie went through is something
that Pat Nixon could could understand
and kind of sympathize with during the
1976 presidential campaign Rosalyn
Carter was on her way to pay her
respects to Lady Bird Johnson whose
husband had been the most recent
Democratic president the day before
their meeting Jimmy Carter's
embarrassing Playboy interview was
published where he talked about
committing adultery in his heart many
times and something else he said in that
very embarrassing interview was that
where he talks about how Nixon and
Johnson both lied and cheated and
distorted the truth and Mary merely
mentioning Johnson and Nixon in the same
breath at that time so close to
Watergate was a nessam of two Democrats
it was very upsetting so here is Rosalyn
Carter in this very awkward position of
paying her respects to Lady Bird Johnson
you know very shortly after this article
ran and she turned rosalind turn to an
aide who was very close with the
Johnsons and said what does mrs. Johnson
think about the interview what should I
say about it and they said you don't say
anything mrs. Carter you're a southern
lady just like mrs. Johnson it won't be
brought up your two lovely southern
ladies just be yourself and it was so I
mean these women there's a code that you
know they date Lady Bird Johnson knew
better than anyone what it was like to
deal with a husband who offended and
upset people at times President Johnson
was not an easy man to live with at all
and so I think that that again shows
they're they're very close
in their understanding another thing
that's interesting and I mentioned this
is the prison-like element and you do
hear Michelle Obama talk very candidly
about wanting to just roll down the
windows of a car you know and have the
freedom to do that this very simple
thing when I interviewed the chief usher
Admiral Steven Roshan who ran the White
House essentially he told me that
Michelle really wanted him to call her
Michelle and she said you know I just I
really want someone to call me Michelle
and not mrs. Obama our first lady and he
said he couldn't do it so then from then
on you know very few people would ever
call her Michelle again even though she
desperately wanted them to and when I
interviewed aides to the Obamas they
said you know this end of two years ago
or a year year-and-a-half ago and they
said they're ready they're done there
she cannot wait to leave the White House
and so I'm sure that that has only
ramped up in the recent months she
misses being able to spend time with
their daughters without being swarmed by
photographers and reporters close Obama
aide has a child around the same age of
one of the Obamas daughters and I talked
to him and he told me that during soccer
season the first lady would tease him
that he would probably be tied up all
weekend doing carpools and he said yeah
probably with a shrug and she said I'm
sure you don't miss it and she replied
oh you'd be surprised so those little
things like carpools they really do seem
to miss and her mother Michelle's mother
is lonely too she isn't a suite on the
third floor I've been told it's not that
you know it sound it sounds much more
luxurious and it is it's just a bedroom
with a small sitting room attached to it
and the head butler who I interviewed
for this book storage Haney he said that
he felt so badly for Marian Robinson one
morning when he was serving her
breakfast he said you know do you want
to get out a little bit and my wife
would love to just take you to the mall
and go out for lunch and so his wife
Shirley took Marian Robinson out to it
undisclosed location because apparently
she goes there a lot and so surely
wouldn't tell me where they went but it
was just a suburban shopping mall and
they had lunch and she said it was
really fun and so it's a very kind of
sweet thing that you know she can't wait
just kind of get out a little bit
herself too and I talked a little bit
about where they physically work from
Michelle Obama works from our East Wing
office and really does keep more of a
distinction between the private and work
life I think with a lot of the other
first ladies especially Nancy Reagan
there there was a little bit of bleeding
over I mean Nancy Reagan was one of the
most involved first lady's in you know
of all time and she was someone who had
you know chief of staff Don Regan
famously fired although other people
wanted and fired as well I mean she was
someone who was influencing who was her
husband's chief of staff was and who was
surrounding him in his cabinet which is
incredibly powerful it's that it's
that's the most powerful position you
could be in it's exciting who's
surrounding the president one aide
called her the human resources
department essentially and I think Nancy
Reagan is really interesting too because
when I interviewed resident staffers
about her they said that she was very
particular and that that could be really
a upsetting and a lot of times you know
she wasn't happy there were stories
about her being so angry if you know the
dessert wasn't exactly what she wanted
if she asked for asparagus and she got
green beans you know there would be hell
to pay and dinners and things like that
but the flip side of that was that she
was also very meticulous and so when the
Gorbachev came for this historic visit
to Washington the first time since
Khrushchev had been here the White House
had never looked more beautiful and she
had the flowers changed three times in
one day and because she understood in
every room I mean it was just she
understood the power of the White House
and the flip side of that is of course
she was criticized for being Queen Nancy
and spending too much money so and it's
also sad I talked to a friend of hers
who described watching Nancy Reagan
after her husband was diagnosed with
Alzheimer's Nancy went to the Republican
convention it was the first time she had
gone without him and she started tearing
up at the podium when she was talking
and this friend called mrs. Reagan up
after
reson said you know I was so happy to
see you be expressive and be so honest
and emotional and and Nancy Reagan said
you know I felt that I had to build a
wall up around myself in the White House
and I could never really let people see
that side of me so I think there's
something to that that she felt that she
had to be kind of the strong one and
when I interviewed Ron Reagan their son
he said that his mother was you know
very brave and she would take a lot of
criticism that President Reagan didn't
want to take he wanted everyone to love
him and she didn't really care people
liked her or not she just wanted to get
things done so you could look at her
legacy as first lady as one of
incredible bravery in some ways I mean
she got she she did get things done and
I talked a little bit about well I mean
there the Nancy raid she did not have
Nancy did not have a great relationship
with a lot of other first ladies she
didn't get along with Barbara Bush there
were even rumors floating that Nancy
Reagan wanted the Carters to move to
Blair House so that she could start
redecorating before the inauguration
which is I mean that would be
unprecedented to make to make a family
do that and she certainly did not offer
to leave the White House early when it
was her turn to move out she and Barbara
Bush had such a bad relationship that
when Barbara had a little idea of what
the residence looked like and she had
been married to the vice president for
eight years she had been rarely invited
to parties and the residents and in his
private diary President George HW Bush
wrote very bluntly in 1988 in an entry
he said Nancy does not like Barbara
Nancy he said was jealous of his wife
she feels that Barbara has the very
things that she and Nancy doesn't have
and that shall never be in Barbara's
class so I think that's a very
complicated relationship between these
women and there was no official tour of
the residence until January 11th for the
Bush's only nine days before they moved
in it was very brief and unsatisfying
and when a negative biography of Nancy
Reagan was published Barbara snapped it
up but slapped another cover on the book
jacket so that no one would know what
she was reading which I mean she is
really very witty and funny and when I
interviewed her I really enjoyed talking
to her but I could absolutely see her
doing something like that so that's a
little bit about the bad blood there's
also you know some bad blood between
Barbara Bush and Hillary Clinton it's
very interesting in 1992 there's this
Vanity Fair article during the campaign
Hillary is quoted in this article
talking about George HW Bush's alleged
affair and she says in the store in the
article apparently it's all well-known
in Washington and Barbara Bush who was
incredibly defensive and loyal to her
husband was so upset by this she she had
this reporter come up to the West City
Hall and I interviewed him and he
described how she was sitting there
dressed in a very pretty lilac suit and
but her intentions were very clear you
know it was the focus of her day was
making sure that nobody believes these
sick and ugly rumors she called them but
it really was sinking low and in her
minds in Barbara Bush's mind it was
really like going against the code of
what you can do as First Lady Hillary
Clinton of course was not a typical you
know candidate's wife and she was much
more involved in some of that harsher
you know campaigning and she was much
more involved in a lot of these women
are in policy obviously and it's very
interesting what public statements have
been made you know in a 2000 interview
four months before her held eldest son
was elected president and almost a
decade after Hillary first criticized
her husband Barbara Bush went on the
record and said Laura would not get into
foreign affairs or controversial
subjects I think she would rather make a
positive impact on the country and then
she said I'm not criticizing mrs.
Clinton but it's like oil and water
we're talking about two different people
I think Laura blinks of others which is
very kind of catty and you know clearly
what she's saying there and then I did
talk to a few people who told me that
when George HW Bush visits when Bill
Clinton visits George HW Bush at their
Kennebunkport
town there's a reason why Hillary
Clinton isn't in tow you know they're
just not close and I think it's hard for
some of these people to bury the hatchet
these campaigns as we see now are just
very passionate and very personal and I
talked a little bit about the security
issue I did talk to some staffers for
this book who really wanted to drill
home the idea that they're more
concerned than ever about security in
the White House that more part-time
staff is being hired and that they think
the first family is is definitely more
vulnerable now than they've ever been
before in an effort to cut down on cost
the White House isn't having as many
permanent staffers work during state
dinners and this was something that
three of these resident staffers were
very passionate about telling me and I
felt that they you know they they really
are so loyal to the White House and to
the just no matter who is president and
so they really wanted to make sure that
that point was out there they feel that
this is not something that you should be
trying to skimp you know or save money
on security issues so anyway obviously
as we go forward with this election I'm
actually I was saying I have to do it
afterward for the paperback version of
this book and it's supposed to come out
in January around the inauguration so I
have to do one for Melania and one on
Bill which is really interesting and
challenging to do one for each so it
will see but it's going to be it's a
fascinating time to be talking about the
presidential spouse because I think it's
at changing completely and no matter who
wins it will be transforming the role
probably forever so I would love to take
questions if you have any
thank you very much thank you this is a
question you've actually already
answered sort of half of at least but I
think there's some other some other
parts the question is has it gotten
harder just in general for the first
lady or the first spouse to live in the
White House and the security aspects of
that her almost have almost certainly
gotten worse than they ever were but I'm
wondering whether than I don't know the
new journalism has changed to the news
cycles gotten shorter and maybe just the
increasing involvement of first ladies
in in policy and so forth stay starting
with Nancy Reagan but moving to Hillary
Clinton whether the job is job is
tougher I was struck by this comment
that it's like a prison and just
wondering whether that's something that
they feel now and that they didn't feel
in the past beyond even the security
aspects of it that's a good question
thank you I think that they feel it more
now I mean the Obamas have had it's been
kind of debated but they initially at
least had a you know more more threats
and so that does up the security and the
feeling of it being like a prison but I
think for a long time I mean like Betty
Ford describing or one-bedroom apartment
in the White House you know the feeling
of living and not being fully in control
of your life and having to give up your
career I think that's something that
will probably change if Bill Clinton
becomes First Gentleman that maybe we
will see a first lady allowed to
continue a career as long as there are
not a conflicts of interest I just think
she's a little bit I think Michelle
Obama might be more honest about the
feeling that a lot of these women have
had although Barbara Bush really loved
living in the White House and she told
me she would move back there and a heart
beetus you didn't have to do anything
you know so I mean it just really
depends on the personality I think Laura
Bush also really enjoyed it so I say
it's entirely dependent on who is in
that position but I do think the
security is only going to get to be a
bigger and bigger issue which is why it
is I think a bit concerning that they're
cutting down on the full-time staff who
know what's going on and recognize
people and things like that about the
journalism part is getting tougher to
deal with journalists for the part of
first ladies or the family in general or
not I don't know the answer to that I
think that they control the message at
the White House pretty well I mean I
think that they are able to kind of
avoid you know she doesn't do many
interviews she does a lot of like
late-night you know television Ellen and
you know Jimmy Fallon and things like
that but it's very controlled and I
actually think that this White House is
one of the you know I only was I was a
White House reporter during the first
term of the Obama administration so my
experience is with this White House but
when I spoke with people who covered the
Bush White House they said it was
slightly easier I think with each
administration as you know as technology
evolves they can tweet and Facebook and
Instagram and just kind of control the
message and not have to answer reporters
questions as much so I guess I don't
just an impression I had the journalist
feel more comfortable now asking
uncomfortable questions of these be
respect and that that uh that got
protected I don't know yeah I when I was
researching Nixon I was really
interested in Julie Nixon during
Watergate doing actually standing in for
her father at a press conference and one
of the reporters said you know this is
absurd that you're taking questions your
father should be here answering these
questions and I felt that was very blunt
of a report so I don't know I think that
access is not necessarily I mean there
was a time when Kennedy and Johnson were
friends with reporters and had like real
relationship with them so I mean from a
I tend to take the reporter's
perspective on that but yeah
thank you kind of an unfair question but
by the way the residence was an
excellent book thank you
who was your favorite of the modern
first ladies you don't have to answer
the opposite I would like to do that I
really think that's like that to me
that's an easy question because I think
that Betty Ford who was there for the
shortest amount of time two and a half
years you know is the first lady who's
had the biggest impact long term because
of the Betty Ford Center and also
because she had breast cancer in the
White House had a mastectomy and openly
talks about it and was very very honest
and interviews of famous 16 minutes
interview where she talks about how she
was a teenager she would smoke pot I
mean she was just incredibly honest to a
fault in a lot of cases and I think
she's the one but I mean the Betty Ford
Center to actually admit that you have
an addiction problem and then to help
other people I think that's pretty
powerful and Eleanor Roosevelt of course
but I don't talk about her that much how
about the ones that you've met that you
talk to who this book oh I think Rosalyn
Carter is the most honest and blunt of
the first lady's and she talks about
still being upset that her husband lost
in 1980 and it's the biggest regret of
her life and I think that's incredible
that this many years later she's so
passionate about it and it's just I like
the honesty of Rosalyn Carter
I was surprised to learn that Barbara
Bush and Marilyn Quayle didn't get along
yeah I mean they really didn't get along
at all I think some of Marilyn's friends
told me that it was sort of Barbara Bush
had been you know her model of first
lady was Nancy Reagan who didn't treat
her too terribly well and so she kind of
repeated that and didn't treat Marilyn
Quayle that well apparently she was very
cold it was very hard for the quails to
get invitations to state dinners and
very hard for them to get into the
residence and things like that and so
and you'll notice the quails really
don't do interviews there's not much
they've been really very quiet and she
wouldn't talk to me for this book but
there's a lot of just bad feelings there
are also different generations Marilyn
Quayle was a lot younger and had a young
family - thank you um I think something
of great interest to me and Michelle
Obama is a prime example is the first
lady usually has some major national
initiatives the case of Michelle Obama
it was getting schools to have gardens
vegetable gardens and I actually got to
plant such a garden with Michelle Obama
in 2009 just was in the right place at
the right time and it all came together
for our organization natural partners
but it would be interesting for you if
you could come in a little on you know
say Michelle Obama's national initiative
and how that compares with others and
how that tradition got started um I
think that I mean I think of her let's
move campaign and her military families
campaign and as the signature issues but
that is also an important one
absolutely and that kind of ties in with
the healthy eating because the planting
and the vegetable isn't eating organic
and all of that but she's done I think
it's actually a much more ambitious
campaign than people think I said -
actually real change and you know very
significant it is and I mean she's going
up against this huge industry the food
industry I mean Walmart McDonald's these
companies
have like lowered their sodium in their
foods that are offered because of the
let's move campaign and that kind of
pressure that she's brought to bear so I
think that it is an ambitious idea it's
interesting because when I interviewed
some Clinton aides they said that they
thought Michelle Obama hadn't done
enough in the White House you know that
she should have done a lot more and gave
up a lot of gains that Hillary Clinton
had made and so there is a sense that as
someone who went to Princeton and
Harvard maybe she should have done more
I mean that's that goes to the point
you're kind of damned if you do and
damned if you don't
I mean she did she's done a lot of very
good work but they are all expected to
pick some a political issue and I think
hers is surprisingly not controversial
but ambitious and you know yeah
absolutely what would be a runner up for
like the signature campaigns that
they're doing I actually think I mean
Laura Bush came into it with literacy
and you know following in Barbara Bush's
footsteps but then after 9/11 she became
the first first lady to do the
presidential radio address she became
very outspoken on supporting women in
Afghanistan so I think that her whole
kind of because history dictates what
they end up doing I think that that she
ended up being really consequential in
that way does being an advocate for
women in the Middle East but and I guess
they just say no campaign but I think of
those campaigns was kind of stilted and
they're like you're expected to do it I
wasn't I wasn't as interested in the
campaign's as in like the personality of
these women but it's absolutely I think
that Michelle Obama deserves a lot of
credit for let's move in the military
family campaign absolutely I agree thank
you thank you
okay it's a little high you can just you
can just say it loudly okay yeah I'm
sure all right you know it's Hillary
Clinton wins this will be the first time
since George HW Bush that there won't be
young children in the White House and I
was kind of wondering if you could speak
to how culture the culture of the White
House or particularly in the residence
is different when there's younger
children that's a great question because
they all love it when there's younger
children I mean the butler's especially
and they would defend it in the chef's I
mean when I talked to the head pastry
chef he talked about how fun it was to
you know help Chelsea and her friends
cook and they gave them cooking lessons
and I mean there's but especially when
there's really young kids they love that
I mean they describe watching Caroline
and John Kennedy jr. with pitter-patter
of feet in the hallway and you read
these great oral histories from Tish
Baldrige and other Kennedy aides talking
about the dynamic there it's just much
lighter and I think if Hillary Clinton
you know she'll probably bring the grand
hard to grandchildren there to visit so
there will be those that dynamic to it
and when I talk to some social
secretaries they said they think that
Hillary will probably be on the White
House tour you know that it would make
sense for her to want to see where could
she put the cribs for the grandchildren
but there's almost which I just don't
know if there would be time for her to
think about things like that but it's
interesting that the expectation is that
she would be both President and First
Lady at the same time you know because
there's no one to be first lady which is
kind of I think they'll hire a really
experienced social secretary to do a lot
of that stuff because so will not be
doing I realized your article about
actually about how you really Bill
Clinton yeah I I've been saying for
years if
I hope Clinton becomes the president I
really want the inaugural ball talks
that bill wears to be in the Smithsonian
with a yeah absolutely yes and we should
be critiquing what he's wearing every
day in his hair and it's only fair
absolutely thank you
the wives of governors who go on to
become president they've had experience
being the wife of a chief executive I
know and I know in the state where I
lived before I moved down here the wife
of the incumbent governor was in the
public eye always at events and
ribbon-cuttings pics from the newspaper
every other day you know the spouse of
the two spouses of the two senators I
couldn't even tell you their names is
there any difference in the way that
wives of governor's Laura Bush Hillary
Clinton Nancy Reagan is there any
difference in the way that they
approached the role having had some
somewhat equivalent experience yeah
that's a really interesting point when I
talked to Barbara Bush about Hillary
Clinton and I said well the Clintons I
you know I heard that they weren't as
comfortable in the White House and maybe
it's because they weren't used to being
you know surrounded by help and
everything and and Barbara Bush that are
you kidding me she's the wife of a
governor she has a governor's mansion
she was not you know she was used to
being you know in the public eye so like
you're saying I mean she was used to a
degree of help and Rosalyn Carter talked
about how amy was you know three years
old running around in the governor's
mansion and and tourists would be there
taking photos and so for Amy it wasn't a
big deal like it you know the press went
crazy when Amy went to public school
they took photos of her and Rosalind
said you know it was not to us it wasn't
Amy had always grown up in the public
eye and people forget about what it's
like being in the state you know the
press in the state is very consumed with
the governor and his wife and you're
right not the senator and senator
spouses at all which is interesting but
I think they're definitely better
prepared and I think that's why the
Obamas as we all know had just such a
incredibly quick rise to the top they
didn't have any of that Anna sort of
experience and so it's I think it's much
more difficult for people
haven't gone through wheel camp and the
Fords - I mean they describe the kids
putting their feet up on the coffee
table and Betty Ford saying you know
that's Jefferson's coffee table get your
feet off that so it's like fair very he
had only run in one campaign in Michigan
and then suddenly he's president you
know his rise was very Swift so I think
it's of the women who have been married
to a governor have a kind of a leg up in
that way yeah thanks hi I came in late I
apologize are you cover this already but
I'm curious but the staff of the first
lady does that's what's the size of the
staff usually like is that change
depending on who it is is it five or 20
maybe and then is the chief of staff the
first lady a powerful job and in the way
that she must have for the president is
um well Perry you you know this better
than I do president um he's a reporter I
think that I mean Tina Chen Michelle
Obama's chief of staff is very powerful
and everything gets routed through her
and the East Wing right now with the
Obama's very controlled because Michelle
Obama doesn't sort of go into the West
Wing very often Tina Chen is like the
conduit for her the staff size has
changed a lot Rosalyn Carter was the
first first lady to work out of the East
Wing and she really I don't remember the
numbers off the top of my head but I
think it was in like the 20s
I mean expanding the staff and I mean
back when it was Jackie Kennedy you know
the social secretary the chief of staff
the press secretary I mean the press
secretaries are relatively new thing to
you and there's also a deputy press
secretary and so it's it's in if you
know it's certainly more than 20 I think
and then you also have calligraphers who
work out of the East Wing office and
things like that but as the role of
first lady has become bigger and bigger
the staff has gotten bigger and I mean
Hillary Clinton's staff works in the
West Wing also the old executive office
building I mean the staff is kind of it
really depends on who the first lady is
how they want to structure it this White
House is more traditional and that you
know it's very much East Wing Michelle
Obama rarely goes into the West Wing I'm
told
and so I think that if Bill Clinton if
the Clintons move in you know there's
going to be a whole revamping of the
East Wing staff and probably it will be
even more sidelines you know because the
East Wing is always kind of that looked
down upon a little bit by the West Wing
I think there's a bit of a battle of the
sexes still going on you know the mostly
male mostly female and so I think if
Bill Clinton is in this position he will
not really be involved in what's flowers
and guest lists and stuff which will
make the East Wing even less of a force
you know but an event really I think
since we are in a bookstore and we are
on c-span and even though I'm a Democrat
I would like to get a shout out to Laura
Bush for her promotion of the National
Book Festival here in Washington DC
which I think has been tremendous and
has really carried on after her yeah
absolutely no she's done a lot of good
and I was surprised to learn that she's
very she's tougher than a lot of people
might think I mean she's been through a
lot and another thing that I think
though Clinton would be particularly
good at and that people don't think
about is how the first lady is really
the consoler in chief you know these are
the women who after 9/11 for instance go
to memorial services and really have to
be emotional supports for the country
instead of the rock for their husbands
to you and you just think of all the
horrific things that they have to do and
I think people don't necessarily give
someone like Laura Bush enough credit
for for that for what she went through
his first lady that was a really
traumatic time to be first lady
oh the pressures on I wanted ask a
question about Washington DC and the
first lady's relationship or the first
family's relationship to Washington DC I
mean we've seen various you know uh news
stories about outings that some of the
presidents have had and others haven't
really related to DC at all so I'd like
to have your take on that yeah I mean if
you talk to Clinton supporters they'll
say you know if the Clintons come back
they'll be great because Bill Clinton
used to on quiet weekends go to the
Smithsonian you know a gallery of art
and relax you know and that he's very
much a fan of Washington and the culture
and the restaurants and all of that and
they know it very well and that Donald
Trump would be much less kind of wanting
to stay any people even talked about him
not being living in the White House
which I can't imagine that would not I
don't think that would go over very well
most people wouldn't like that but I
think there is yeah it's a very
complicated relationship there are great
stories about Pat Nixon and Hillary
Clinton both putting on baseball caps at
different decades obviously but walking
through the streets you know around the
White House or in Georgetown just trying
to go out for a walk and escape the sort
of claustrophobic life in the White
House so and you do see the Obamas I
mean they do go out to dinner I mean
Michelle Obama every time she goes to
some hot spot like on 14th Street
there's a write up about it I think
there has been some sense that they've
you know done it some good for the food
scene in the city especially her outings
but it's a really complicated
relationship that they have with the
with the town and I think that the
Clintons probably because they are so
experienced in know Washington so well I
think they would probably be going out a
fair amount but I don't know I don't
know
thank you so much thank you
I never I never I said like a zombie -
clearly psychotic